hey everyone Lauren good for wired here
at the Steve Jobs theater in Cupertino
where Apple just wrapped up another
hardware event we saw three new iPhones
you saw the iPhone at ten s which is an
update to last year's ten we saw the
iPhone 10's Mac which has a giant
display and the iPhone 10 are let's go
take a look at a couple of the folks
this is the iPhone 10 s and this is the
iPhone at 10 s max indefinitely people
are going to be calling use the iPhone X
I don't blame you as I've been walking
around I've been saying X and R and s
and all kinds of things but they are the
iPhone 10s line of phones down there
there's also an iPhone 10 our phone
which we don't have right now but I've
got a lot of phones here to show you
let's start with the new iPhone 10 s it
doesn't look really any different from
last year's phone in fact I have it here
thank you for holding that this is last
year's phone as you can see here this is
this year's fun this does come in new
colors it comes in gold which is going
to ship in before it does have
strengthened glass so it's supposed to
be the most durable glass ever on an
iPhone which you're probably going to
need because I've dropped a couple of
these and they do shatter and scratch it
also has a new ip68 waterproof and
dustproof rating so you drop it in the
pool you can leave it in full
a little bit longer and maybe it won't
get damaged but one of the most
interesting things about the new tennis
is it's huge ship so Apple has updated
last year's a 11 Bionic processor watch
to you guessed it the a 12 Bionic
processor it's a super duper high power
and mobile phone chip it's a seven
nanometer chip which I believe Apple is
the first to shift this kind of mobile
chip before qualcomm has said it's going
to do it but it hasn't shipped yet walk
up the first power is a lot of the
high-end Android phones so this is a
great chip in this phone as far as we
know right now a lot of what this is
doing is it's enameling and things like
machine learning and just a faster
processing I mean it's really kind of
powering everything in the phone it's
making photos better it's supposed to
make a battery life a little bit better
so that's one of the things that Apple
really got in the weeds about today at
the event and for a lot of people maybe
they won't care so much but it is one of
the internal upgrades to the phone that
makes it different from last year's
phone the 10s max phone has a lot of the
same internal changes internal updates
as the 10s but this one is obviously
huge you were to compare it to last
year's 8 plus phone which I have right
here you can see if these are pretty
much the same size this one
unfortunately I shattered but this one
now has a 6.5 inch diagonal display so
it has much more display there almost no
bezels here that also means at first
there's no longer a home button it has
the notch here that's where the
face ID front-facing camera live both of
these support face ID both support 3d
touch both have a true tone display both
have the same improvements on the
cameras that includes now you can add a
little bokeh effect adjust the depth on
your portrait photos I mean it has
something called Smart HDR which is
supposed to have zero shutter lag once
again all this is stuff that isn't
exactly revolutionary in terms of what
new iPhones have been what new iPhones
can be they're more evolutionary but
that's kind of what you expect from an
SEO of iPhones this is the new iPhone 10
are one of the biggest differences is
that this feels like an older iPhone
it's got a 6.1 inch diagonal display
compared to the five point eight inch
display on the iPhone 10 s and the five
the six point five inch display on the
iPhone 10's max boot that's a mouthful
this is also an LCD display the other
ones have OLED displays and it's had an
aluminum band around it rather than a
stainless steel band so it feels a
little bit different than the iPhone 10
and the iPhone 10s but it has the same
true depth sensor up here so use the
space ID no home button so RIT home
button has the same 12 megapixel rear
facing camera and it also has the same
age 12 Bionic chip that's in the other
phones overall I have to say I like this
color it's really nice and bright
they're also coral phones there's a leaf
there's a red phone they do look really
nice this is not the first time that
Apple has done candy color and iPhone so
you might remember the iPhone 5c which
came out in 2013 at this point um but
those were plasticky and they didn't
look so nice and this is glass and it
looks pretty nice and because this one's
a little bit cheaper than the other
phones I could picture a lot of people
being into this one so that's the iPhone
tennis tennis Max and ten are two of
them going sale next week the ten are is
going to start shipping until sometime
in October and they're all gonna cost
you
but the 10s is the same price as last
year's ten starts at $9.99 for a 64
gigabyte configuration and a phone and
the tennis max is really expensive
it starts at 1099 so we have officially
entered the era of the $1100 smart ball
is it worth it we don't know yet we
haven't have a chance to test them but
we're certainly going to so be sure to
come right back to Wired we'll have all
the information you need